joe biden continues to maintain he had
no clue afghanistan was about to fall
but his own state department had a
report predicting just that the white
house desperately seeks excuses and the
left continues its attacks on ron
desantis over blocking mask mandates i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government's
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
ben well first we begin with the latest
from afghanistan where the situation
continues to be just awful we now have
tape of toddlers being pulled over the
airport wall by american forces because
people are so desperate to get their
kids out of afghanistan ahead of the
taliban that they are handing their own
children like small babies over to the
american military here's what that tape
looks like
it's just a disaster area meanwhile
video has been taken outside the airport
apparently showing
people basically being crowded into a
ditch by the taliban these are supposed
to be people who are waiting to enter
the airport again this is not a an
organized withdrawal shall we say
and of course enter the gun shot so
things are going beautifully right
outside the airport
sounds great
meanwhile the taliban spent the day
yesterday celebrating because after all
it was the anniversary of the
independence of afghanistan according to
the new york times kabul was many things
on thursday the cast at the airport was
matched by calm and other pockets of the
city some businesses resumed work many
people were trying to get on with their
lives others weren't hiding afraid for
theirs women were scarce there were some
signs of taliban restraint but also
clear evidence its members patrolling
the streets were not afraid to wield
force in fact there is a story from
cnn.com about a photographer who was
basically he got the hell beat out of
him by the taliban and then when they
realized he was a reporter they started
trying to take selfies with him so
everything is well organized over there
the president of the united states is
supposed to address the nation on friday
apparently as the united states tries to
ramp up its troubled evacuation in
afghanistan biden is expected today to
address the furor over the sluggish
process stymied by mayhem in kabul and
delays in washington that threatens to
strand thousands of afghans desperate to
flee the taliban takeover biden is
expected to speak at 1 pm in washington
he's defended the pull out from
afghanistan while promising not to
abandon the afghans who risked their
lives well i mean he's walked back that
promise pretty clearly as we'll see in
just one moment the united states has
rushed to troops and diplomatic
reinforcements to kabul in recent days
to speed up visa processing for afghans
american commanders are negotiating
daily with their taliban counterparts to
ensure the evacuees can reach the
airport because we are pathetic okay
we're we're begging the taliban we say
negotiating with the taliban mean
begging the taliban the british and the
french have been sending out military
patrols to go pick up their citizens and
bring them to the airport the united
states however
is hunkered down behind the walls of
kabul airport fearful that if the united
states walks out the taliban will attack
them and then joe biden will have to
overturn his promise to get all the
troops out by august 31st and insert
more troops into kabul turning a
disaster area into a full-scale
conflagration all because the man is a
thousands are waiting fearfully
outside the airport gates according to
the new york times where taliban
soldiers have attacked people's people
with sticks and rifle butts as afghans
clutching travel documents camped
outside amid taliban checkpoints and
tangles of concertina wire anxious
crowds were being pressed up against
blast walls with women and children
being hoisted into the arms of u.s
soldiers on the other side
the taliban's unpredictability and
history of brutality have set off a rush
to escape especially among afghans who
worked alongside us and nato forces that
of course is no surprise given the fact
that
so
many people are going to be left there
murdered i mean that that is the the
taliban are apparently going door to
door according to daily wire the taliban
are intensifying their search for
afghans who help the united states and
have a list of people they intend to
quote unquote question and punish which
is code for murder according to a
thursday report from the new york times
based on a document prepared by the
united nations the development seems to
complicate assurances from the biden
administration that the taliban are
somewhat reformed from their previous
iteration biden seemed to hint at a
changing interpretation of the taliban's
newfound commitment to freedom in his
recent interview with abc's george
stephanopoulos
meanwhile the taliban are also going
door-to-door seeking first christians
they're searching through phones for
bible apps to make sure that there are
no christians in country according to
the daily wire afghan christians are
reportedly fleeing to the mountains in a
desperate attempt to escape the taliban
who are going door to door trying to
kill them things are going great in
other words an internet an underground
church that partners with frontier
alliance international has reported that
the taliban are targeting christians for
death according to fai the taliban has a
hit list of known christians they are
targeting to pursue and kill the us
embassy is defunct there's no longer a
safe place for believers to take refuge
all borders to neighboring countries are
closed all flights to and from have been
halted with the exception of private
planes people are fleeing into the
mountains looking for asylum they're
fully reliant on god who's the only one
who can and will protect them the
taliban are going door-to-door taking
women and children the people must mark
their house with an ex if they have a
girl over 12 years old so the taliban
can take them if they find a young girl
and the house was not marked they will
execute the entire family if a married
woman 25 years or older has been found
the taliban promptly killed her husband
do whatever they want to her and then
sell her as a sex slave is according to
again the frontier alliance
international a christian ngo
meanwhile u.s allied afghan forces are
completely in hiding according to the
new york times thousands of afghan
security force members managed to make
it to other countries over the past few
weeks as the taliban advanced others
managed to negotiate surrender and went
back to their homes some kept their
weapons and joined the taliban they were
all part of the sudden atomization of
the national security forces the united
states and its allies spend tens of
billions of dollars to arm train and
stand against the taliban tens of
thousands of other afghan grunts
commandos and spies who fought to the
end despite the talk in washington that
the afghan forces simply gave up have
been left behind they're now on the run
hiding and hunted by the taliban there's
no way out said for reading afghan
commando and a text message to an
american soldier who fought with him
fareed who agreed to be identified by
first name only said he was hiding in
the mountains of eastern afghanistan
trapped after the regular army units
surrendered around him i am praying to
be saved he said militants are
threatening to arrest or punish family
members if they can't find the people
they are looking for according to former
afghan officials most spoke on condition
of anonymity to protect friends and
loved ones still hiding in afghanistan
the taliban is coming through records of
the ministry of defense and interior and
the headquarters of afghanistan's spy
service drawing up lists of operatives
to search for there are more and more
reports militants are exacting swift and
fatal revenge when they are found which
of course is not exactly a shock so
things are going beautifully
in a second we'll get to the latest on
the evacuation efforts which are a
complete leap show first let's talk
about the thing you set on at your
office so let's face it your office a
lot of hours every day you get up at the
end of the day your back kind of hurts
it's because you're sitting on a crappy
office chair why would you not be
sitting on the world's greatest chair
i'm talking of course about the x chair
it's like sitting on a cloud it's like
god made a chair the x-chair extra has
you covered for your office chair needs
the extra can give you a massage while
you're sitting at your desk it can warm
your back on cold mornings it can cool
you off on hot days lmax temperature
regulation will take your seating
comfort to a whole new level patent
pending lmx allows you to experience
cooling heat and massage in your low
back extrus patented dynamic variable
lumbar support was already best in class
with incredible responsive low back
support now with elemx your comfort is
guaranteed you won't believe the
difference until you feel it for
yourself imagine regulating your body
temperature and getting massage therapy
while you're working x-char lmx delivers
cooling heat and massage technology
directly to your core regulating body
temp helping increase blood flow muscle
recovery and energy all perks that make
working from home or the office a joy go
to
xchairshapiro.com right now it's letter
x chair shapiro.com
xchairshapiro.com or call one eight four
four four x chair for a hundred bucks
off your order extra has a 30-day
guarantee of complete comfort you can
finance your purchase for as little as
30 bucks a month go to xchairshapiro.com
right now use codexwheels for free
xwheel bladecasters as well
xchairshapiro.com alrighty so meanwhile
the united states plans to get people
out continues to be
not much according to jackie heinrich
who is writing for fox news she's the
white house correspondent she says that
sources have told her the state
department is looking for non-military
ways to stage and move americans and
others in kabul as an alternative to
military forces being deployed into
kabul for rescues so i guess we're going
to you know just send randos into kabul
to try and bring americans through the
gauntlet that has now been created by
the taliban around the kabul airport the
state department did not dispute this
information they said quote our first
priority is the safety and security of
the american people we will continue to
uphold that commitment oh will you
the state department above all of the
other departments is the one to blame
the state department is a disaster
disaster area meanwhile john kirby over
the pentagon he's the spokesperson he
was asked you know you keep saying that
we're trying to get our people out and
yet we have not deployed any military
patrols to go pick up americans who are
stranded in kabul
why is it
that the brits and the french can do it
but we cannot
if the british can take their
paratroopers and they can get in
vehicles and go get their people and get
them to the airport why can't the us do
that if there is a deal with the taliban
to provide safe passage why is it left
to the americans outside of that ring
to get there on their own why can't we
send vehicles to go get them we we we
have not seen
any great impediments uh to the safe
passage that the taliban have agreed to
facilitate americans are getting through
those checkpoints and they are getting
on to the base on the airfield and they
are being flown out of kabul okay that
is not exactly what we are hearing from
on the ground where we are hearing that
many afghanistan that many certainly the
afghans are stuck in kabul but many
americans are not willing to run the
gauntlet because they're afraid of
walking outside their front door
and and the taliban's mercy lasts as
long as the taliban's mercy lasts let's
face what's going on here the reality is
when we say we're negotiating with the
taliban what we mean by that is we're
bribing them this is going to come out
over the next six months i promise you
that the united states is sending
pallets of cash to the world's worst
human beings because joe biden couldn't
keep it in his pants when it came to
withdrawing from afghanistan
i mean that that really is what's going
on here according to defense one
evacuation operations at hamid karzai
international airport are starting to
normalize but with the stark reality the
us movements including any troop
extension past august 31st now mustn't
be negotiated with the taliban the
pentagon acknowledged on thursday
john kirby said quote i think it's a
fundamental fact of reality of where we
are that communications and a certain
measure of agreement with the taliban on
what we're trying to accomplish has to
occur about 7 000 people a mix of
americans afghans and other foreign
nationals have left kabul on u.s
military aircraft since non-combatant
evacuation operations began last week
the us has flown about 12 000 people out
of afghanistan since july
however
we're still we've still got thousands
and thousands of americans who are still
stuck in kabul and tens of thousands of
afghan allies who are stuck in kabul at
a state department press conference
thursday spokesman ned price
acknowledged processing has been slow
but was improving he says there are six
thousand people at the airport right now
who have been fully processed by our
consular team and will soon board planes
in the meantime however there are planes
that are leaving literally half empty
20 planes were expected to depart
overnight on thursday state will double
the number of consular offices on
officers on the ground by friday says
ned price we'll have the capacity we
need to process as many individuals as
we can fill the flights the evacuation
has more of a rhythm in the 24 hours the
last 24 hours he said for example u.s
troops have opened and manned more gates
at the airport allowing faster processes
of evacuees
and the crowds that swarmed the tarmacs
have been pushed out but there are
currently more airplane seats than there
are passengers
which means that the processing is not
going all that well
the us would like to move between five
and nine thousand people per day
over the last 24 hours they flew out 2
000 said taylor
there are at least 15 000 americans
still in kabul and more than 70 000
afghans who works with the us government
and their families
all of those people are going to be
stopped by the way
even the u.s citizens may hesitate to
move from their homes according to
defense one the us government said
wednesday it cannot guarantee their safe
passage
price had every report of someone unable
for whatever reason to reach the airport
is something we take seriously we're
doing everything we can mechanically
logistically but then of course there's
also the diplomatic element of this as
well
so
in other words no americans are still
stuck there and this process is not in
fact going particularly smoothly
meanwhile there was this debacle over
the last 24 hours where the united
states state department apparently was
selling flights i'm not kidding you they
were selling the flights for
essentially two thousand dollars
according to politico even though u.s
officials tell nat sec daily and others
that evacuation flights from kabul will
be free people trying to catch a plane
in the afghan capital say differently
one person said state department staff
were seeking large payments up to two
thousand dollars from american
passengers and even more from non-us
citizens
when we relayed what this person told us
to the state department a spokesperson
didn't deny this is happening the
spokesperson said u.s law requires
evacuation assistance to private u.s
citizens or third country nationals be
provided on a reimbursable basis to the
maximum extent practicable the situation
is extremely fluid we're working to
overcome obstacles as they rise
so now they're trying to walk this back
they're saying no no now we're gonna
make the flights free but it took the
press discovering that they were trying
to charge people trying to escape
afghanistan two thousand dollars in
order to leave
for that to become an issue all right so
this all has international implications
as well apparently the united states
asked we're not we're not the point
we're just asking our enemies for help
and they're all like
here's the latest on that according to
the wall street journal russian
president vladimir putin during a june
16th summit meeting with president biden
objected to any role for american forces
in central asian countries at all senior
us and russian officials said
undercutting the us military's efforts
to act against new terrorist dangers
after its afghanistan withdrawal
remember
joe biden said that we would still be
able to carry out the over the horizon
missions we needed to we'd have air
bases we'd be able to still monitor
terrorist traffic in afghanistan no we
won't i mean end of story no we don't
have any resources on the ground we have
no bases in country and we have no bases
anywhere nearby pakistan cut a deal with
the taliban to kick us out and russia is
denying us the ability to build any
bases or have a base anywhere nearby
the previously unreported exchange
between the u.s and russian leaders has
complicated the us military's options
for basing drones and other
counter-terrorism forces and countries
bordering landlocked afghanistan that
challenge has deepened with the collapse
over the weekend of the afghan
government and armed forces
the exchange also indicates moscow is
more determined to try to maintain
central asia as a sphere of influence
than to expand cooperation with a new
american president over the turmoil in
afghanistan former and current u.s
official said
uh yeah no no bleep
that there's a shock you mean the
russians aren't interested in helping us
who could have foreseen this cataclysmic
event
who could have foreseen that the
russians and the chinese and the taliban
might not be all that helpful to us in
fighting terrorism
without access to central asian nations
like uzbekistan kyrgyzstan and
tajikistan the us would need to rely on
bases in qatar other arab gulf states
and u.s navy aircraft carriers in the
indian ocean to fly aircraft to
afghanistan
flight times from the gulf states are so
long a u.s drone might spend more than
60 of its mission flying to and from
afghanistan from a u.s base in qatar
that would limit the time for conducting
reconnaissance or carrying out strikes
over the country because the drones
basically run out of fuel
so this is all going really really
really well the good news is that joe
biden is enamored with it he loves it he
loves it and when he's not lying about
how he got to this decision here's how
he got to the decision he woke up one
morning he had his can of insurer he
watched part of an episode of matlock
and then he farted out his decision
that's how he came to this decision
there's no logic to it he was told in
advance by pretty much everyone that
this was the world's worst decision he
was told by his dod that he needed to
leave some skeletal troops there at
least until the evacuation was complete
he was told by his state department this
was a mistake he was told by everyone
this was a bad idea but bad ideas have
never stopped joe biden before
that's kind of amusing when donald trump
was president there was all this talk
about how you know trump isn't really
running his administration the people
around him are running his
administration
and in reality many of the people around
trump were constant checks on his bad
ideas i very often trump would have a
bad idea militarily speaking like what
if we precipitously pulled out from
syria and james mattis would step in and
go you know mr president you can't do
that it's a bad idea and trump would go
okay fine and then he would listen
joe biden listens to no one and so his
advisors have just gone along with the
worst foreign policy decision in my
lifetime
i just went right along with it and
enabled it after advising him it was a
terrible idea
there was no internal bucking there was
no there are no leaks to the press there
was no talk in advance about how this
was going to go
they just went along with it they let
the adult old man figure out what the
policy would be a policy that he had
locked in from 2010 and on even though
the war in afghanistan has radically
shifted since 2010 given the fact that
we radically downscaled our troop
commitment in afghanistan post 2014.
the united states has not had more than
12 13 000 troops in the country at any
time since 2014.
and at the time that we left we had 2
500 troops officially in country
to provide again a base from which to
fight terrorism
but joe biden at least he has sort of
these moments of refreshing honesty
because every so often it breaks through
and joe biden did this interview with
george stephanopoulos
in which he freely admits that whether
like he first tried to blame this on
trump you'll recall remember he said
this is oh trump had cut this really bad
deal in doha qatar with the with the
taliban and we had to abide by that deal
and now japan's like yeah whether or not
that deal was made i was going to do it
which is the actual truth
would you withdraw troops like this even
if president trump had not made that
deal with the taliban
i would have tried to figure out how to
withdraw those troops yes because look
george
there is no good time
to leave afghanistan
15 years ago would have been a problem
15 years from now
the basic choice is
am i going to send your sons and your
daughters to war
in afghanistan
in afghanistan in perpetuity okay so
when he says there's no good time to
leave afghanistan uh the answer to that
is
right which is probably why we should
have left some skeleton troops there at
a minimum
but he was committed to this he's
committed to this by the way there's
news breaking this morning that the
situation in afghanistan is getting
worse according to sasha ingberg who's a
national security reporter for newsy
previously at npr and national
geographic a source says the situation
in afghanistan is rapidly deteriorating
we've had americans get beaten
throughout the night one of them an
american woman was beaten twice even
though she was carrying a us passport
their reports of sure chaos breaking out
again in afghanistan for all the talk
about how this thing is starting to lock
down it continues to be chaos
at the airport in afghanistan
it's it's it's a disaster area
and yes joe biden was warned about this
yes joe biden was warned about of course
he was
now joe biden lied about that right he
went on stefanopoulos and in the course
of about 30 seconds said he wasn't
warned about it and then realized that
that was going to be out at his lie and
then he went to the i don't recall
defense right the i don't recall defense
in politics is what you do it's the
lawyerly way of avoiding any sort of
actual blame
because if you don't recall that can't
be argued with
and since everybody assumes that joe
biden has some form of memory loss
anyway it's actually credible here's joe
biden going from i was never told to i
don't recall in in the space about 30
seconds
your top military advisors warned
against withdrawing on this timeline
they wanted you to keep about 2 500 no
they didn't it was split
that wasn't true
they didn't tell you that they wanted
troops to stay
no not at not in terms of whether we
were going to get out in a time frame
all troops
they didn't argue against that so no no
one told your military advisor did not
tell you no we should just keep 2500
troops it's been a stable situation for
the last several years we can do that we
can continue to do that no no one said
that to me that i can recall no okay and
you can tell he's lying right there
right he realizes he's trapped himself
and uh and that he's lying uh in fact we
know for a fact that he was informed by
many of his advisors that this was a
terrible idea this has been widely
reported in fact back in april gensake
confirmed that some advisors were
telling biden to leave troops right this
is publicly
can you explain the rationale for why
president biden went against the advice
of military commanders who recommended
leaving 2500 troops on the ground in
afghanistan
well i think that's a over
characterization of every military
leader and i don't think they've all
provided their point of view no military
commander wants to stay forever they
insist that this is not some insist this
is not entire the time to leave some
opponents of his decision oh so some
have said it's not what so i was told
that that was not there was no
opposition to that
by joe biden right then right he doesn't
recall anybody saying that to him we now
have reports from the wall street
journal from the new york times from
pretty much every major media
publication saying that joe biden was
told by everyone up to and including by
the way lloyd austin his secretary of
defense as well as
the wonderful mark belly the chairman of
the joint chiefs of staff he was told by
everyone this is a bad idea and he went
ahead and he did it anyway because he's
a stubborn old coot and he has decided
that his bad foreign policy ideas need
to be as as barack obama once said about
joe biden don't underestimate joe's
ability to screw things up
yeah well the american people did and
now we're going to pay for it in a
pretty serious way we'll get to more of
this in just one second because we now
have the breaking story that the state
department overtly informed joe biden
this was going to be a disaster like
weeks ago first let us talk about a
great gift you can get for your family
you can get for your friends for
yourself i'm talking about the gift of a
professionally painted portrait get a
professional hand-painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price at paintyourlife.com
in my house we have a beautiful
hand-painted portrait of me and my wife
and two of my three kids
on a beach in hawaii we actually need to
go get a new portrait because we have
squishy baby now you should do the same
you can even combine photos of people or
places you love into one painting choose
from a team of world-class artists and
work with them until every detail is
perfect user-friendly platform makes it
easy to order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes it's
fast you can receive your portrait in as
little as two weeks send any picture
yourself your children your family a
special place someone you love to may
not be around anymore a cherished pet
even an action shot of you or your kids
playing your favorite sport you can do
anything with these portraits and they
look great at paintyourlife.com there's
no risk if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now it's limited
time offer you get 20 off your painting
that is correct 20 off and free shipping
to get this special offer text the word
ben to 64 000 that has been to 64 000
text the word ben to 64 000 paint your
life celebrate the moments that matter
most terms apply available at
paintyourlife.com terms again text ben
to 64 000 to get started okay so here is
the big story of the day the big story
of the day aside from the fact that the
situation in in afghanistan continues to
be just an utter complete disaster area
richard engel reporting this morning
what was supposed to be an organized
evacuation of foreigners and afghans who
worked with us nato is rapidly becoming
a chaotic humanitarian airlift
and just complete chaos breaking out
over there there's an internal state
department cable that warned that kabul
would collapse in july
according to the wall street journal
an internal state department memo last
month warned top agency officials of the
potential collapse of kabul soon after
the us's august 31st troop withdrawal
deadline in afghanistan according to a
u.s official and a person familiar with
the document the classified cable
represents the clearest evidence yet
that the administration had been warned
by its own officials on the ground that
the taliban's advance was imminent and
afghanistan's military may be unable to
stop it the cable was sent via the state
department's confidential descent
channel and warned of rapid
territoriality gains by the taliban and
the subsequent collapse of afghan
security forces and offered
recommendations on ways to mitigate the
crisis and speed up evacuation the cable
was dated july 13th
july 13th now the reason i mentioned the
significance of that date is because
five days earlier joe biden had gone on
national television and assured the
american people the taliban would not
take over the country and this would not
look like a saigon
five days earlier
as of last weekend some eighteen
thousand afghans who applied for the
us's special immigrant visa program
as well as their families remained on
the ground in afghanistan in all 23 u.s
embassy staffers all americans signed
the july 13th cable the u.s official
said there was a rush to deliver it
given circumstances on the ground the
cable was sent to our wonderful
secretary of state anthony blinken and
the director of policy planning solomon
ahmed
lincoln received the cable and reviewed
it according to people familiar with the
exchange who added that contingency
planning was already underway when it
was when it was received and that
blinken welcomed their feedback
state department spokesman ned price
declined to address the cable but told
the wall street journal lincoln reads
every descent and reviews every reply
the existence of the confidential state
department cable adds to an expanding
debate involving the white house
pentagon and intelligence services over
what u.s officials understood about
assessments of afghanistan's stability
again it is very clear at this point
that biden was warned eight ways from
sunday
it is very obvious to anyone who is
watching that this was a disaster area
unfolding
and uh biden couldn't care less he
couldn't care less
and it is it is incredible how this this
glowing
this this giant glowing sun of empathy
president biden has no empathy
whatsoever for what's going on on the
ground over in afghanistan for the
americans who are stuck there for the
afghans who are stuck there for anybody
because he wanted to do the things that
he wanted to do and he gets
his umbrage begins when you start asking
him tough questions this has been true
by the way throughout his career there
was always this picture of biden that he
was a wonderful warm guy any time he was
asked a tough question by literally
anyone throughout his campaign he turned
into the look fat guy you remember that
there was a guy a bernie sanders
supporter who asked him a tough question
and he started insulting him as fat i
mean that's who joe biden is
so in this interview with george
stephanopoulos he was just fully
delusional and in umbrage mode so at one
point by the way he mentioned that he
said we don't have any troops in syria
which is weird since we have 900 troops
in syria but i mean the man can be
forgiven that since he doesn't remember
what he had for breakfast this morning
but more than that he then did this this
is an amazing clip joe biden told george
stephanopoulos nobody's being killed at
the kabul airport right now he said
everything's everything's fine over
there
still a lot of pandemonium outside the
airport well there is but look
but no one's being killed right now god
forgive me for if i'm wrong about that
but no one's being killed right now no
one's being killed and then he knocks on
wood he knocks on wood you're the
president of the united states
he's knocking on wood that no one's been
you know could ensure that no one gets
killed over there if you hadn't
abandoned the country without any plan
whatsoever that would ensure that nobody
got killed or if you said to the taliban
listen you let all of our guys in or
american air power is going to start
going after you
now you may be all fun and games for the
moment but just remember we still the
most powerful air force on planet earth
so you let all of our people through
right now or the bombs start falling on
this on the heads of your soldiers but
he's not doing any of that and by the
way he's wrong when he says that people
aren't being killed at knock on wood
here is cnn yesterday
since the taliban seized kabul on sunday
12 people have been killed that
according according to the reuters news
agency taliban fighters toting machine
guns and a soundtrack of gunfire or
fueling this unease and anxiety among
afghans look here cnn photographer
capturing these images huddled masses
outside kabul airport's east gate rows
and rows of men women and children
clustered together waiting on a way out
that for some may never materialize and
by the way a lot of people are pointing
out people who don't want to take in
some of these afghan refugees again if
you if you're a translator with the
american armed services and you have
american soldiers who are vouching for
you it seems to me that your case to be
brought into the united states as a
refugee is pretty good but in any case
if you're talking about this a lot of
people have been saying look at how many
men there are in these photos right
because those are the ones who worked as
the translators there weren't a lot of
women who were working as translators
for the american armed services in
afghanistan in any case biden's just
lying when he says nobody's been killed
no a lot of i mean
people fell from airplanes dude on tape
on tape
but remember captain empathy over here
he's never been empathetic toward this
sort of stuff i mean if you go all the
way back like to the actual fall of
saigon
you'll remember that joe biden actually
said
by the actual fall of saigon that the
united states had no obligation to
evacuate a single member of south
vietnam like not a single person and
we'd abandon them to their fate hundreds
of thousands of people got into boats to
float off the coast of vietnam to escape
the on-russian communist hordes and joe
biden said this quote i do not believe
the united states has an obligation
moral or otherwise to evacuate foreign
nationals other than perhaps an
estimated 1800 diplomatic personnel
assigned to foreign embassies in saigon
the united states has no obligation to
evacuate one or one hundred thousand in
one south vietnamese as i read the
language of the bill the evacuation of
americans in south vietnam conceivably
could be endangered because of the
provisions also permitting the
evacuation of untold numbers of foreign
nationals so this goes back 40 years for
this jackass
i mean it's amazing it goes back almost
half a century
joe biden's
complete lack of care about people who
are being victimized by the regimes that
democrats have empowered
it's pretty incredible
meanwhile by the way forget about the
afghan nationals for a second the
americans are still stuck there
now the state department's been trying
to downplay that here was ned price
yesterday saying that the americans
being blocked from the airport they're a
small number it's just congestion it's
not chaos uh this is contrary to every
report we're receiving from on the
ground
we have a relatively large cadre of
consular officers on the ground in kabul
right now they are in regular and
constant contact with american citizens
i can tell you that they have received
as of a couple hours ago a small handful
of reports from american citizens who
weren't able to reach the airport for
whatever reason we've seen the reports
of congestion my understanding is that
things are moving quite efficiently at
this hour at the airport uh at the
airport now oh really things are moving
well now clarissa ward reporting for cnn
says quote this is one of the most
harrowing things i've experienced what
is she talking about the scene at the
kabul airport according to the
washington post a chaotic and dangerous
dynamic at kabul's airport showed few
signs of relenting thursday as thousands
of people attempting to board flights
faced beatings by taliban guards the
crush of heaven crowds and interminable
spells in the dust and heat while
waiting to escape afghanistan
several people said thursday they'd
received confusing signals from the u.s
about how exactly they were supposed to
leave sending emails from the state
department urging them to go to the
airport only to find there was no one to
receive them or to answer their
questions on how to board flights we
arrived at 6am said a 39 year old
librarian a dual us afghan citizen who
came with his wife and two kids after
receiving an email invitation from from
the state department from 6am until 6pm
the gate did not open there is no person
to address our concerns and now we are
learning that the taliban is targeting
journalists who report on the chaos the
german broadcaster deutsche welle said a
close relative of one of its journalists
had been murdered by taliban fighters
the relative was shot as militants went
house to house searching for the
journalists in western afghanistan
according to the news organization
and um you know clarissa ward and her
crew are now inside the airport but
she's saying that again inside the
airport it is not a lot better than it
is outside the airport the pentagon
spokesperson by the way ned price he
can't or john kirby rather he can't even
say how many americans are even in
afghanistan at this point
how many americans american citizens
remain in
afghanistan i don't know the state
department would be a better place to go
for an estimate of how many americans
are afghanistan or in and around kabul
that is not a figure that the united
states military
would would know and
i think as you also know not every
american citizen in another country uh
uh that there's no obligation that they
register their presence uh and and that
we and that you can have a perfect
accurate count okay in order to make
anybody believe that the administration
has any level of control the biden
administration has now been put in the
position of becoming the pr wing for the
taliban this is not a surprise you saw
that divided in the obama administration
did the exact same thing with iran obama
came into office wanting iran to be
established as a sort of regional power
for no reason at all because again he
had perverse foreign policy ideas that
made no sense in the real world and so
what this meant is he wanted to kind of
deal with taliban with the iranians
so he lied to the american people and so
did ben rhodes his national security
adviser they just lied they they they
went out there and they said that there
was a moderate wing of the iranians and
we were emboldening the moderate
wing of the iranian government and then
we spent years defending the iranian
government oh really they're moderate oh
really they're moderating oh really
they're getting better oh you know
they're really not so bad is there
anything really to worry about i mean
that like they're going to get better
guys i mean they want to be legitimate
players on the world stage we became the
pr wing for the iranian mullahs even as
they fostered terrorism around the
region even as they murdered tens of
thousands of people in places like syria
and lebanon and yemen
even as they funded hamas
it was the united states and barack
obama's administration who are
soft-peddling the evils of the iranian
regime now we're doing the exact same
thing with the taliban because you see
in order to make americans believe
everything is going to be okay in
afghanistan we have to believe that the
taliban are a different sort of taliban
maybe they're changing their stripes you
know no guarantees but maybe they're
going to be better this time around
now is there any evidence whatsoever
like at all that they're better this
time around they're literally just
shooting people they're going around and
hunting journalists
they pledged the same thing in 96 when
they first took over afghanistan that
they have now which is pardon for
everybody and then by pardon they mean
you will be dead i mean that's basically
what they mean but you've now turned the
white house of the united states into a
pr wing for the worst people on earth
the same way that obama did with the
iranians so here for example was the
president of the united states joe biden
saying you know
the taliban they're probably going
through some sort of existential crisis
right now
you know they have to decide whether
they want to be part of the
international community here's the thing
they've already decided the answer is no
and they are not going through an
existential crisis the west is going
through an existential crisis because
the west has no idea what it believes
the west doesn't know what it stands for
aside from the evils of supposed
inherent white supremacy embedded in all
of our institutions and
transgenderism the west has basically
very few principles to which it is
certainly committed at this point we
don't know what we stand for we don't
know why we stand for the things we
stand for we are going through an
existential crisis the taliban are going
through a victory dance because a bunch
of regressive barbaric cavemen from the
8th century just defeated the most
powerful military in the history of the
world
by the way for the second time because
they did this to the soviets in the 80s
so now they're proclaiming victory on
the exact same thing even though really
the two instances shouldn't be
comparable the united states was holding
the line in afghanistan 2 500 troops
the difference is the taliban have a 1
000 year time horizon and we have about
a 20-year time horizon in the united
states we get bored after 20 years and
we're like oh well this is an endless
war you know what an endless war means
to the taliban
you know what an endless war means to
the people in afghanistan afghanistan
has essentially been in a state of war
since at least 1979.
so an endless war to them does not look
like an endless war to us and so they
can declare victory after having their
asses kicked all over the map for 20
years because they outlasted us
okay but in any case joe biden has now
become the pr wing for the taliban this
is what he has to do now
i think they're going through
sort of an existential crisis about do
they want to be recognized
by the international communities being a
legitimate government
i'm not sure they do
but look they have they care about their
beliefs more well they do
but they also care about whether they
have food need
whether they have an income that can
make any money and run an economy they
care about whether or not they can hold
together the society that they in fact
say they care so much about
what an absolute joke the president of
the united and there he is they they
they want legitimacy and the same of the
hamas wants legitimacy guys it's all
these terrorist groups they just want
legitimacy
the president of the united states is
now running cover for the taliban that's
the only thing you can take away from
that clip
i'm not sure that they want legitimacy
but you know they do want to make sure
that they can run the economy they want
to make sure i mean wouldn't they want
to be welcomed into the family of
nations by the way it's this exact same
sort of arrogance that led to a lot of
the nation-building project in the first
place they're just like us guys they
want to make sure that they're that
their country still runs they have the
same priorities we do
john kirby at the pentagon was
specifically asked whether the biden
administration considers the taliban an
enemy now this should have a pretty
obvious answer
the answer is yes the taliban are the
worst people on the planet the taliban
are responsible for thousands of
american deaths the taliban are going
around murdering our allies yes they are
our enemy they've continued to be our
enemy but because joe biden just
surrendered to them he now has to say
that it's not a surrender by pretending
they're not our enemy so that's what
john kirby does here he just avoids the
question as to whether the taliban are
our enemy
does the us military consider the
taliban an enemy
our focus right now uh the the the thing
we're we're working against right now is
is time and space and we want to get as
many people out of kabul as we can uh in
as little amount of time as we can that
is called a not answer at all
the question was are the taliban our
enemy
the answer is we're trying to get
americans out
so i guess we're the pr wing for the
taliban now that's exciting in a second
we'll get to what joe biden's calculus
here is because it's pretty obvious what
his calculus is why he's doing all of
this and what his angle here is because
you look at this and i look at this and
we say this is the worst foreign policy
disaster of the last 40 years at least
since the fall of iran in 79
maybe since the end of world war ii
considering it's so self-inflicted i
mean at least when iran fell we really
had very little to do with it well when
it comes to this we are the complete
cause of it this is the i think it's the
worst foreign policy disaster for
america
man i i honestly i i'm hard-pressed to
think of a worse foreign power
the end of vietnam was not even as much
of a foreign policy disaster as this is
truly
but but joe biden has a plan we'll get
to the actual plan in one second first
let us talk about a simple fact if you
have a medical problem that could be
taken care of quickly and easily why
wouldn't you just go get it solved with
roman you get a free online evaluation
and ongoing care for erectile
dysfunction all from the comfort and
privacy of your home roman ready means
confidence the confidence you know you
can rise to the occasion in the moment a
u.s licensed healthcare professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships to you free with
two day shipping the whole process is
straightforward convenient and discreet
getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com
complete an online visit take care of
your edu without leaving your home
complete an online visit today to
connect with the us licensed healthcare
professional and get it taken care of
right now go to getroman.com bend today
if you're prescribed get 50 off your
first month of ed treatment make sure
you're ready to have confidence and
control this summer roman ready go check
out roman right now if you've got a
problem like erectile dysfunction can be
embarrassing to talk about maybe you
want to ignore it don't just go talk
about it discreetly and easily get the
treatment you need at getroman.com today
if prescribed get 50
off your first month of ed treatment
larry we'll get to more on the disaster
in afghanistan plus we'll get to kovit
as well first if you'd like to stay well
read and informed the daily wire readers
pass is for you for just four bucks a
month our daily wires readers pass
unlocks exclusive editorial content it
unpacks trending political and cultural
topics penned by everyone from me to
candace owens to dan crenshaw plus you
can catch our latest analysis pieces
like my own titled the fight over
identity or take a deep dive with
readers past collections different
series of articles on a given topic
current collections include the hunter
biden files and blm the organization
behind a movement all that for four
bucks a month when you sign up with
readers pass you also get access to the
morning wire newsletter a monday through
saturday email covering the top stories
you need to know available only to daily
wire members all of this can be yours
for just four bucks a month so act fast
because right now we are offering a one
month free trial it's a good deal it's
also never been a better time to take it
so what exactly are you waiting for get
informed get a reader's pass today
also as you may or may not know the
sweet baby gang is an exclusive club
only matt walsh's listeners are a part
of if you're one of the gang i have
excellent news the sweet baby gang is in
need of a sweet baby anthem and the
daily wire is opening up for submissions
matt is looking for an original song
that embodies exactly what the sweet
baby gang is all submissions should be
in the form of youtube video links will
be judged american idol style by me and
the other daily warehouse i think you
know who simon kell will be but you the
viewer will be voting on which song wins
to enter go to dailywire.com
sbg submissions end on august 25th if
you think you've got what it takes to
impress matt walsh you better get
started voting will take place on labor
day so tune in to matt walsh's youtube
channel to watch the judging of the
submissions the winner will be announced
september 8th on the matt wall show will
wear the crown of the creator of the
most important anthem to have ever been
anthemed again to enter your song into
competition go to dailywire.com sbg we
all look forward to hearing it you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
meanwhile the media reaction to what joe
biden is doing is beginning to rush in
it is not good so what does biden think
that he is doing here according to
reuters biden basically thinks he's
going to wait it out reuters says
president joe biden is brushing off
criticism of his administration's
chaotic afghanistan withdrawal because
he and his aides believe the political
fallout at home will be limited
according to white house allies and
administration officials that of course
is not a giant shock considering
that he said 10 years ago that uh f that
with regard to whether there would be
consequences for withdrawal nixon and
kissinger got away with it which is an
amazing thing considering that neither
nixon nor kissinger were actually
responsible for the vietnam withdrawal
right gerald ford was president at the
time nixon had been gone for a while and
it was the democratic congress that
actually caused the vietnam withdrawal
in the first place but the idea here is
that he's just going to be able to
outlive this joe biden will just outlive
this right we'll all forget about it
we'll all move on uh i am not nearly so
sanguine particularly since it seems
like this administration is still trying
to figure out whether or not they're
going to leave people behind
brianna keeler over at cnn she actually
asked directly the white house
communications director
this would be kate bettingfield she
asked her directly
are you prepared to people leave to
leave people behind in afghanistan and
kate bettingfield said we're doing
everything we can to get as many people
out who want to get out before the
august 31st deadline
who set that deadline
like that that's the taliban setting
that deadline right i have a feeling
that if you leave a bunch of americans
there kate and joe i have a feeling that
the fallout may not be limited i have a
feeling that people are going to be kind
of pissed if you leave thousands of
americans in kabul because you're so
stupid that you left them in the hands
of the taliban meanwhile the british and
the french somehow are sending their
paratroopers in to get people out
i have a feeling americans might not
take particularly kindly to all of that
one of the things that has fascinated me
about the the situation in afghanistan
right now
is the media coverage thereof because
the media coverage has been really good
like really accurate quite good
hyper critical of president biden
everywhere from like the european press
to the american press and it got me
wondering why why are the media and this
is literally the first time in my
lifetime that a democrat has done
something egregious and the media have
been all over it the media never do this
even when bill clinton was getting
caught in the oval office with his pants
down the media were like oh well you
know boys will be boys
even when it was barack obama completely
botching things in iraq to the extent
that isis rose it was well you know that
was really the consequence of a bad iraq
war and he can't really be blamed and
after all biden who's going to go it was
obama who's going to go in and fix the
problem
this is the first time i've ever seen i
think in my entire adult lifetime where
democrats do something so egregious that
even the media are forced to look at it
and go this is horrifying
and it really is across the spectrum
there are very few media defenders of
the biden administration at this point
cnn's clerus award has been doing
excellent work on the ground at cnn she
of course is incredibly brave she's been
on the ground in kabul dealing with all
of this and she is leading the charge
here
the lack of clear information the rumor
mill is an overdrive there's hysteria
you have taliban fighters with whips
with guns you have us and uk soldiers
who are not allowing people in you have
mixed messaging coming through about
what kind of paperwork you need and how
you can get on flight and where you can
go i mean it is just an absolute mess
and we heard president biden say
yesterday in his uh comments to abc news
that this is not a failure and i think a
lot of people outside that airport
particularly those taking the kinds of
extreme actions we're just talking about
would like to know if this isn't failure
what does failure look like exactly okay
and you're hearing the same thing from
jake tapper over at cnn you're hearing
the same thing from msnbc's kelly
o'donnell who says biden is pretty
obviously ducking the press at this
point which pretty clearly is
does the white house have a good
explanation so if if the president now
says chaos was inevitable
then
are they acknowledging that he misled us
so was that mislead a month ago on
purpose because they didn't want to
offend the afghan government well
they're not acknowledging that
discrepancy yet we've had no opportunity
no briefing no ability to get a real
sense of that what they are saying is
that they had planned for and expected
that there could be a fall but the
timing has been what they've been
focused on that it wouldn't be as
precipitous as we have seen happen okay
everybody acknowledging this is a mess
new york times jonathan martin he says
yeah it's pretty clear that the
administration is lying to us
you have the president talking about
chaos being inevitable sure the chaos
was inevitable if you're talking about a
taliban takeover of kabul if you're
talking about a dangerous situation and
just the crumbling of humanitarian and
human rights but it was not expected to
be chaos when you're talking about
evacuating embassy staff at the very
last minute evacuating and trying to
figure out what to do with the afghan
staffers at the very last minute that
was not predicted and that should have
been handled differently he said the
opposite the previous month and i think
that's the big challenge for him
politically is that he has a paper trail
of statements literally as joe biden
would say saying the opposite then
in fact what happened and i think
there's no willingness on his part to
acknowledge his previous statements here
and sort of eat that my first time in my
adult lifetime that the media are
actually covering this stuff accurately
the first time
and
you know it does raise the question as
to why i think there are a couple of
answers the first answer is that the
media actually thought afghanistan was
the good war many of them were embedded
with american troops many of them got to
know afghans on the ground and uh and
now they are they're realizing that
they've been lied to by joe biden
and i i think they're insulted by that
and they should be insulted by that
all right meanwhile the situation with
regard to covet has continued to to be
the narrative that joe biden hope props
him up right so so much right now is joe
biden blowing things in afghanistan and
then turning and wheeling and trying to
clock somebody over covet now here's the
thing it was joe biden who promised on
july 4 that we were done
and if you'd set the metrics properly we
would have been done on july 4th meaning
does every adult in america have the
ability to get the shot the answer is
yes
so what are we talking about now
really what are we talking about
the the democrats set an unrealistic
standard with regard to covet
and the unrealistic standard was zero
covet they will never acknowledge this
that their goal is actually zero covet
but that is their goal
and and that goal is not realistic
because covet is going to be with us
until the end of time there are hundreds
of millions of people who have code
right now
there are hundreds of millions of people
who've already had covet we already have
a large majority of the adult population
of the united states that has had either
coveted or the jab at this point so
there's no end point there's no endpoint
for the democrats and so democrats
continue to try and manufacture this
idea that they know how to deal with
kovid
and the republicans are obstructing that
in the hopes that the american people
will blame republicans for number one
joe biden's failure to set any sort of
actual reasonable metrics with regard to
covet number two democrats broad-scale
desire to lock down and mask people for
the end of time and three to distract
from his gigantic enormous historic
world historic failure in afghanistan
and so they're going to go right back to
the kova drawing board so ron desantis
has become their their target of
opportunity they've headed to sansa
since the beginning of the pandemic
because he presides over the oldest
state in the country outside of maine
which again has seven people in a moose
desantis has performed admirably i live
in florida
it is a relief to see a politician who
actually follows the data and recognizes
that mask mandates are completely
useless there is no actual evidence that
mask mandates not masks mask mandates do
anything when it comes to delta it is
pretty clear that cloth masks are very
ineffective okay this is not me saying
this this is michael osterholm the
former biden advisor saying this there's
people like scott gottlieb pointing out
that cloth masks are not particularly
effective against delta because the
viral load on delta is much much higher
than the viral load on the alpha variant
b117
so
when
when ron desantis says there's no
evidence that kids should be masked in
schools he is absolutely correct now
let's be clear about what ron desantis
has done in florida by the way he has
not said that kids cannot mask in school
that's not what he said he has said that
local school districts will not receive
funding if they ban kids from school for
not masking that is a difference the
media have lied about this they've said
that he's banned masks in schools that
is not correct if you want to master
your kid in school you are still capable
of doing so there's no evidence you
should there's no evidence that masking
in schools is particularly effective
first of all kids are not good at
wearing masks second of all most of the
kids are wearing cloth masks
third of all if you want to ask your kid
with an 1995 i suppose you're free to do
so although there are a lot of studies
suggesting that mass masking around kids
is not good for their mental development
and that there may be physical
consequences to kids breathing in their
own carbon dioxide all day
but putting all of that aside
ron desantis has not handled things
poorly we are seeing upticks in
virtually every state in the union
florida it looks like by the way already
has seen its peak in terms of cases and
deaths according to world domiters you
can see the case numbers are already
declining over the last week or so the
death numbers have been declining pretty
steeply over the last week or so in
florida despite the media focusing
incessantly on florida not louisiana
which is an actual large-scale rolling
disaster but florida because louisiana
has a democratic governor florida does
not but desantis was ripping biden and
the democrats hope to redirect toward
kovid because again they don't want
anybody talking about afghanistan here
is a ronda santa's slamming biden
i think trump was right to say we needed
to come home from afghanistan how you do
that matters when you're leaving
thousands of americans to fend for
themselves behind enemy lines that
matters when you're leaving billions of
dollars in military equipment for our
enemies to just take that matters it's
going to make that area a disaster
obviously americans are at risk and sean
you know who's looking at this china
russia north korea all of our
adversaries are taking the measure of
joe biden and they see that this is not
somebody who's capable of leading uh
with conviction and and leading on the
world stage okay everybody knows this so
joe biden's idea is let's redirect
toward covet
and let's do it with policy that is
never ending the the masking of children
has become the the point du jour
this is the thing that democrats and
left would love to talk about is masking
kids so anthony fauci who can always be
counted on to take a series of
conflicting decisions and and can also
also be counted on to do so with great
confidence like he'll take two positions
that are in complete conflict with one
another over the course of a year and
then he will say each with equal
confidence so here he is saying it's
time to mask up kids again can he cite a
study like one study showing that
mandatory masking of children has been
effective
the answer is he cannot because those
studies do not exist the answer is he
cannot because those studies do not
exist there is no evidence that masking
of kid is effective or by the way
necessary because thank god the delta
variance is no more deadly for kids as
far as the data that we have seen than
was the alpha variant which means it is
highly not deadly for kids again i'm
going to say to you the cdc statistics
on age okay here are the cdc statistics
on age i'm looking at them right now
okay according to the cdc a grand total
this is updated as of august 18 2021.
two days ago
the grand total of people in the united
states under the age of 18 who have died
involving covet 19
involving copper 19 right not just of
kobe 19 involving kobe 19 this is the
cdc's language
0-17 a cohort of 73 million americans
361. we are not seeing a radical uptick
in death among the young we're not
okay anybody who's telling you
differently is lying to you it is not
true
i looked at the stats a week ago
since august 11th a grand total of seven
children people under the age of 18 have
died of covet 19 in the united states
out of a cohort of 73 million
okay no we are not seeing a radical
exponential spike in death rates for
kids but
if the left can convince you that your
kids are in danger they can continue to
focus in on an issue where they think
they have a winning hand because then
they get to claim that republicans just
don't care if kids die because here's
anthony fauci doing this routine
masks are an important thing for the
mitigation of the transmission and the
acquisition of infection
that they are they are very important
particularly when you have a highly
highly transmissible virus in the form
of the delta variant and that's the
reason why when you talk about the extra
added degree of protection
even in a school system where you may
have vaccinated teachers and some of the
children may be vaccinated you want to
wear a mask to protect the children so
that they could continue to be in school
in person in classes so that we don't
get the deleterious effects on the child
of again keeping them out of school you
want to do that but you want to do it
safely okay notice the lack of logic
here okay so he says we have to make
sure that we mask all the kids because
otherwise the kids might get sick okay
now number one kids who are getting sick
from covered as a general rule and i'm
talking statistically do not get
seriously ill from covert
okay so then he says we have to make
sure that we don't shut down schools
right we have to keep them in school i
have a question what is your standard
for keeping them in school
seriously what is your standard if your
standard because there this shows that
all they care about is zero covet
if your kid had a cold okay let's just
take a completely different disease a
different coronavirus your kid had a
cold in school
your kid transmitted that cold in school
to the other kids
did they shut down the class has that
ever happened any time your entire life
did happen when you were a kid or when
your kids or kids of course not that's
very silly so case count is not
necessarily what matters here the
question is is anyone getting seriously
ill among the children if the answer is
no why are you shutting down classes
well you actually have to explain what
is the metric for shutting down classes
the metric seems to be zero covered if
there are no cases of covet among kids
we keep the classes open but what i am
saying is that that is an idiotic
standard
why should i care particularly much if a
bunch of kids get colds i never have
before i don't particularly now
and if we're worried about the teachers
the teachers should all be vaccinated
and if they don't want to get vaccinated
they can wear an n95 that one's on them
what we are really doing here and
everybody knows it is we are masking up
the kids to protect the teachers or to
make people's faint-hearted parents feel
better about themselves that's what we
are doing here
okay that is not rooted in data linked
to danger for children
because again the danger to children
from covet is exorbitantly low extremely
low
361 kids dead over the course of the
last half year every one of those is a
tragedy but 361 kids under the age of 18
have died in the united states from
covid over the course of the last year
and a half
at the same exact period of time same
exact period of time the number of kids
who have died from other diseases is
much much much higher
the number of kids who have died from
for example pneumonia is 865 over the
course of the same amount of time
okay even the flu which basically didn't
exist last year got wiped out by
covington apparently even 188 kids died
of the flu in the last year and a half
so about half the number of kids died of
the flu as diet of covid
if you're looking at the amount of
deadlines you have to look back at the
the asian flu epidemic that happened
in 2009 2010 that particular flu
epidemic didn't actually
it was more deadly for kids than this is
like there is no metric here none at all
which by the way i mean this is
this by the way is the reason sorry not
the asian flu the swine flu the swine
flu from april 2009 to april 2010
resulted in about 1282 deaths of kids
under the age of 18.
okay so it's deadlier did anybody shut
down schools for it of course not that's
incredibly silly
okay but they continue to argue about
asking kids why because it allows them
to do the political thing of suggesting
that republicans are the worst people in
the world so here for example is don
lemon doing just that again completely
data free just nonsense
how is it freedom to force children who
are too young to be vaccinated into
schools where they could be exposed to a
deadly virus surrounded by people
hold on a second so where they could be
exposed to a deadly virus not for them
not for them
where are the stats showing this is a
highly deadly virus for children they
don't exist they don't exist
but this clod is saying this sort of
stuff to scare the hell out of parent
i know this is happening because in my
own community there are a bunch of
parents who are freaked out about kovit
hitting their kids when the stats do not
bear it out they do not bear it out at
all
and by the way there's no evidence that
even female ask your kids is going to do
a damn bitter thing
right there's no evidence of this
anyway here's don lemon again this is
all political this is not data driven it
is not science driven
putting politics ahead of life-saving
science
like those governors are encouraging
people to do
it is just depraved
people are dying all across this country
people with loved ones who are grieving
tonight
these are people who didn't have to die
okay stop it right here okay
he's such a he's such a liar these are
people who who didn't have to die if
only we had mass mandates mass mandates
have not worked anywhere on earth there
is no evidence that mask mandates not
masks mask mandates because here's the
thing when people are scared of the
virus they mask up you don't need a
mandate when people aren't scared of the
virus it doesn't matter if you have a
mandate they don't mess up
and when it comes to covid when it comes
to the delta variant cloth mass ain't
doing the job you need a 95 or a k on 95
according to best available data
by the way in sweden they never masked
kids according to martin kaldorf who's a
professor at harvard medical school
quote with open schools and no masks for
ages 1 through 15 in sweden there were
zero coveted deaths among its 1.8
million children during the first wave
teachers had a lower risk than average
of other professions so we knew early on
that schools are safe without masks
okay we also know that the uk didn't
really mask
according to the according to
fortune.com as delta infections spiked
coveted cases in schools actually fell
for parents wary of sending their kids
off to school here's a rare bit of
comforting data fewer than one in 100
school students and staff in england
tested positive for covet 19 in june the
capper there was no mass mandate in the
schools at the time
this came as delta variant cases were
peaking across not just england but the
whole of the uk
and again
other countries are not super crazy the
way that we are apparently here's the
head of the uk department of education
or an advisor named dr susan hopkins
talking about why kids don't need masks
in looking at it we've talked to
educationalists public health and
clinical specialists
and the consensus view is very strongly
to not advise school children a primary
school age to wear face coverings
this for two reasons one is that they
can have difficulties wearing them and
keeping them on all day and the second
part of that is that it's really
important that they can see facial
expressions in order to develop their
communications and language skills
okay yes correct okay so the uk has it
what about us
we're doing so much crap that is
superstitious pagan nonsense again
another element of these superstitious
pagan nonsense remember um all of these
plastic barriers that people have put up
and so all last year in my kids
classroom for example they had these
plexiglas barriers in front of them
right this is supposed to block covet
for some odd reason
my kid sitting behind a plastic barrier
not on all four sides right not like it
was a box made of plastic like just a
screen in front of them this was
supposed to block covet now according to
the new york times it turns out that's
crap tara parker pope says covet
precautions have turned many parts of
our world into a giant salad bar with
plastic barriers separating sales clerks
from shoppers dividing shoppers and nail
salons and shielding students from their
classmates intuition tells us a plastic
shield would be protective against germs
but scientists who study aerosols
airflow and ventilation say much of the
time the barriers don't help and
probably give people a false sense of
security sometimes the barriers can make
things worse research suggests that in
some instances a barrier protecting a
clerk behind a checkout counter may
redirect the germs to another worker or
customer rows of clear plastic shields
like you might find in nail salon or
classroom can also impede normal airflow
and ventilation
under normal conditions in stores
classrooms and offices exhaled breath
particles disperse carried by air
currents and depending on the
ventilation system are replaced by fresh
air roughly every 15 to 30 minutes but
if you erect plastic barriers that can
change air flow in a room disrupt normal
ventilation and create dead zones where
viral aerosol particles can build up and
become highly concentrated says lindsay
maher professor of civil and
environmental engineering at virginia
tech and one of the world's leading
experts on viral transmission quote if
you have a forest of barriers in a
classroom it's going to interfere with
proper ventilation of that room
everybody's aerosols are going to be
trapped and stuck there and building up
and they will end up spreading beyond
your own desk
okay so just to get this straight over
the course of the pandemic we went from
masks are bad according to voucher masks
are not only good but the best
two we need plastic barriers super
important to plastic barriers may in
fact make things worse
two
we have to have six feet of distancing
but also six feet of distancing comes
from absolutely nowhere like if you ask
the cdc where six feet of social
distancing comes from they have no they
have no idea it's a standard that comes
from nowhere but it's all the science
guys it's the science because don lemon
says it's the science and by the way
anybody who is worried about getting a
vaccine i'm gonna do a vaccine if
they're young right if anybody who
actually looks at their own risk factors
and says listen i think i'm young and
i'm healthy i'm probably not going to
get super sick from covid19 because just
the odds are in my favor
and you know i'm not super comfortable
with like the modern vaccine those
people are apparently anti-vax crazies
according to everybody
quote from the washington post today
federal health officials are
investigating emerging reports that the
modernity coronavirus vaccine may be
associated with a higher risk of a heart
condition called myocarditis in younger
adults than previously believed
according to two people familiar with
the review the investigation which
involves the fda and center for disease
control is focused on canadian data that
suggests the modern vaccine may carry a
higher risk for young people than the
fisher bioin tech vaccine especially for
males below the age of 30 or so
the two people who described the
investigation spoke on condition of
anonymity because they were not
authorized to discuss it
moderna did not respond to a request for
comment
in a statement the cd said its advisory
committee on immunization practices has
and continues to review reports of
myocarditis and pericarditis following
cova-19 mrna vaccination cdc fda our
vaccine safety partners are actively
monitoring these reports one individual
said the canadian data indicates there
might be a two and a half times higher
incidence of myocarditis in those who
get madonna compared with the pfizer
bioentec vaccine
it's still extremely rare so again this
is not an anti-vaccine point
i still think that all factors being
taken into consideration for the vast
for nearly everyone the vaccine is a
good idea
at least for people who are not children
but
people who are looking around and saying
i feel like i'm not being told all the
risks
mean that's
not
totally irrational especially again if
you are very young and if your risk
factors are very low
again to go back to those cdc death data
by age
it's not just that this thing is very
not deadly for kids
this thing is
is not particularly deadly for adults
who are under the age of 30.
right if you look at the actual
statistics from the cdc
and across the course of this entire
pandemic the entire pandemic more people
in the united states aged 18 to 29 have
died of pneumonia that have died of
covet in the same period
right so it's much more deadly than the
flu for people who are 18 to 29 like a
lot more deadly than the flu for people
who are aged 18 to 29
but it's not more deadly than pneumonia
and also
again like you are a rational human
being you get to take your risk factors
into account
but the idea here is that if you take
risk factors into account this means
that you're very bad
here's the bottom line everybody gets to
make their own decision now we are all
rational human beings we all get to make
our own decision about our own health
and when it comes to whether to take a
vaccine or not i have ideas of whether
you should take it i think generally you
should unless you have some really
compelling reason not to i think you
should take the vaccine if you're in
adults
with that said
we all have our free choice it's been
available for a while we're now done but
the left has to keep this alive and they
must keep this alive explicitly for
political purposes and now more than
ever they have to keep it alive for
political purposes because as we exit
the summer and we enter the winter and
the delta spike shifts
from the seasonally hot states like
florida and texas and shifts into the
midwest and maybe into the northeast
you're gonna start seeing all the covid
talk start to fade just a little it
can't be quite as political as it's been
and right now is the time to make hay
for the democrats they have to make hay
right now because their president is
completely destroying america's foreign
policy and it turns out that that their
push for tyranny at home is not all that
popular either alrighty we'll be back
here a little bit later today with an
additional hour of content first you
cannot forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you head on
over to dailywire.com at 7 pm eastern 6
pm central tune in i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin